Прихована реклама - один з улюблених прийомів українських політиків.
Адже дозволяє обійти вимогу законодавства
звітувати, скільки витрачається на передвиборну агітацію.
До того ж, це зручний спосіб маніпуляції виборцями.
Тому кандидати в президенти частенько "грішать" прихованою рекламою.
Ось які засоби вони для цього використовують.
Президент України Петро Порошенко офіційно не пішов у відпустку на час передвиборчої кампанії.
Це зручно, адже важко відокремити його діяльність на чолі держави від передвиборної агітації.
Ще з минулого року президент активно здійснює поїздки в регіони,
де він урочисто відкриває ділянки відремонтованих доріг,
новобудови, навчальні заклади, спортивні комплекси тощо.
А на початку цього року Порошенко вирушив у так званий томос-тур
після того, як Православна церква України отримала автокефалію.
На зустрічах з громадою він демонстрував томос і позував для ЗМІ з представниками церкви.
Після гучної критики президент дещо згорнув масштаби свого томос-турне,
але й досі піариться на темі церкви.
Так було, зокрема, під час виступу на Франківщині 18 лютого.
Одразу два турне країною відбуваються нині за участю кандидата в президенти
Володимира Зеленського -"Квартал 95" і "Ліга Сміху".
Вдень влаштовують безкоштовний благодійний концерт для бюджетників, а увечері - платне шоу.
Перед початком концерту глядачам вмикають рекламний ролик серіалу "Слуга народу" -
саме так називається новоспечена партія Володимира Зеленського.
Сам Зеленський перед кожним виступом стверджує, що це не агітація, а просто концерт:
Однак громадянська мережа "Опора" вже не раз фіксувала роздачу друкованих
агітаційних матеріалів за кандидата Зеленського перед концертами.
Окрім того, більшість жартів під час концерту -
проти головних конкурентів коміка у президентських перегонах.
Ознаки прихованої агітації спостерігачі з Комітету виборців України вбачають і у фільмі "Слуга народу",
де Володимир Зеленський грає роль президента Голобородька.
У КВУ вважають, що показ фільму має бути профінансований із виборчого фонду як агітація.
Традиційна форма агітації - подарунки виборцям.
Часто їх немає у фінансовій звітності,
тому спостерігачі класифікують це теж як приховану рекламу.
Так, народний депутат від "Батьківщини" дарував на Полтавщині велосипеди медикам
та автомобіль військовим, агітуючи в обох випадках за лідерку партії Юлію Тимошенко.
А на Сумщині партійний осередок "Батьківщини" роздавав на новорічні свята подарункові пакунки,
музичні інструменти і побутову техніку.
За даними Інституту масової інформації, Юлія Тимошенко також стала лідеркою
з політичної "джинси" в українських інтернет-виданнях -
тобто за кількістю матеріалів з ознаками прихованої реклами.
Своє автобусне турне регіонами України кандидат у президенти Олег Ляшко називає "ляшкобусом".
Під виглядом обговоренням проблем з освітянами, медиками та іншими категоріями виборців,
Ляшко щедро роздає обіцянки й агітує за себе.
Іноді він стрімить зустрічі з виборцями у соцмережах - прямо під час руху автобуса.
Як з'ясував громадський рух "Чесно",
протягом останніх двох з половиною років "Радикальна партія" Олега Ляшка
витратила 25 мільйонів державних коштів на привітання зі святами,
оплату телевізійних ефірів Ляшка та на "джинсу".
Попри це свої візити на національні та регіональні телеканали,
де Ляшко виступає гострим критиком влади і захисником усіх знедолених,
він ніколи не декларує як платні чи рекламні.
Тобто від глядачів приховано, що ефіри рекламні.
А це, на думку спостерігачів, також є прикладом прихованої реклами.